[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sanctuary
pandora sanctuary place you can escape
but only you want more of explore us and
reach a different type of hero style
killers can turn a siren into a zero
brick by brick we double crib the
stories that most of us say can only
feel shaky from troubled lips but here
you load your life into a clip movies
and magazines like nothing you've ever
seen i mean
over a century of summers not for the
faint-hearted villains of our hunters a
wild life from demand it's the
arrives
wild
life
memories of newcomers problems resolved
will revolve the shotguns and sniper
rifles life evolves from the righteous
you knock one the homicidal might change
that immaculately covered big strange
facts i think i might stay
sanctuary
sanctuary
[Music]
is
sanctuary
[Music]
sanctuary
b
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
once
again
[Music]
[Music]
it's a lovely day in flame rock refuge
this place used to be really nice until
the handsome sorcerer messed everything
up
wait didn't you just say the sorcerer
messed up the town why would things be
lovely
uh whoops what i meant to say is it's
eternal night
and you hear spooky music
and the whole area kind of smells like
buds and dead people
suddenly you're attacked by a horde of
skelemans they start shooting at you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you get close to the entrance to flame
rock refuge but suddenly the handsome
sorcerer's pet dragon appears surprise
attack
you try to attack the dragon but your
attacks do nothing
the dragon attacks
[Music]
[Music]
uh you can't start your campaign with a
boss fight players can't win okay how
about a new boss
he's a skeleton and his name is
mr
bony
pants guy
[Music]
[Music]
wanna hear
[Music]
all right there we go hey everybody
we're going to get started in just a
couple minutes but i wanted to come out
and give you
a little bit of information about what
is happening and what's going on
this pax west show is going to be a
little bit different in that we need
everybody to participate in here they're
going to be different points during the
show when we're going to ask for
audience participation and we want you
guys to feel comfortable yelling out and
cheering and making selections and
getting involved so let's try it
everybody yell
yell again
[Applause]
one more time
all right all right everybody feels good
about yelling out and yell making
selections because it's going to be
coming real for you in a couple minutes
here i'm good borderlands 3 uh uh game
play all right thanks everybody for
being here we'll get started at the top
of the hour thanks everybody like three
sessions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're about to get caught in the clap
trap rap
trap when it comes to this
didn't come to my birthday party
without giving me a chance all i wanted
to do was help out a dance one step to
the left one step to the right just
don't let it be unless you're ready for
a fight
check it out
oh
hey
hey
shelf
check it out
check it out new bonuses this week check
it out
train
rides
work to your minion y'all
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage founder of gearbox
entertainment randy pitchford
oh my god look at you guys
oh my god
i i i don't think i can spit this far
nobody's gonna throw their feces at me
right is this okay
oh my god look at you guys
i am so glad to be here i am
like you guys can be anywhere in the
world i could be anywhere in the world
but we're here back at pax tonight it's
happening we're here
it's happening
i've um i've been coming to pack since
the very beginning and i've been doing i
love this i love this moment and you
don't you don't realize what you have
until you miss it am i right like
this is a big moment so i am telling you
i am so happy to be here with you guys
thank you guys for coming and hanging
out this is going to be this is going to
be amazing i don't know what you guys
did
during uh the pandemic but i didn't
leave my house for two years
and
i
i don't know how you passed the time
obviously played a lot of video games
right
i also built a lot of lego did anybody
uh i got into lego uh this was my uh
this is my dining room table
i built a lot of lego i ended up
building like a whole city uh i got
really good at it um
uh uh
and and after i got through like a huge
number of sets i started to get bored so
i started to um i started to do mosaics
you know have you ever done that where
you take like flat pieces and you make
pictures you get one of those big flats
one of those big base plates and you
make pictures and i got really good at
it and i made
i made a mosaic for you guys it took me
about five hours
and you want to see it
um this is i made this for you guys and
i think you're really gonna like it uh
that's that's me you can see the stop
motion of me uh
building one uh but this this is the one
i got for you right now check this out
what is that
oh wait a minute
i've uh lost a piece here
let's get that one in there
all right so this is the shift code you
guys and this is not just any shift code
this is the mother of all shift codes
this guy is worth uh 10 uh golden keys
in borderlands 2 10 golden keys in
borderlands 3 a diamond key in
borderlands 3 and 10 skeleton keys in
wonderland so take a picture take a
picture of the screen make sure you get
it
oh man um wow this is cool oh wow
the full house you guys are all the way
back there um
how many people is this your first pax
is there anybody here that this is your
first packs
oh wow a lot of you wow welcome welcome
welcome to the to the family welcome to
the pax family welcome to the gearbox
family um you know a lot of there's a
lot of different panels you can go to at
pax obviously it's getting geared up
again so you know maybe it's a little
lighter on content this year but um
usually like when video game developers
do panels they just get a bunch of
people standing behind or sitting behind
a table and they answer questions and
talk we kind of do a little show but we
do have a lot of stuff to share and a
lot of really cool things and i think
you're going to be excited about it
how many people have been
been to a pax before how many people
have been yes welcome back
how many people have been coming to
gearbox panels for gearbox shows for
more than say three three uh times
wow
amazing
i i love it we've been doing this for a
long time um and i was thinking back and
some of you guys that have been doing
this with us for a long time that are
like part that i think are part of the
family like you remember you know we
some of it some people that are here for
the first time maybe they discovered
gearbox through wonderlands
but uh you know of course there's
borderlands and we had a lot of games
before that so i asked i asked the guys
to bring up a video game shelf of all of
the games uh from gearbox software
throughout our history dan can steve
awesome
so these are look at all these titles
this is like this is my life right here
like
like i've dedicated my life to creating
this stuff with all the awesome people
at gearbox we got our brothers-in-arms
games and you know this is uh
we got half-life and halo and we did a
james bond game with electronic arts
back in the day of course all the
borderlands stuff um and there's even
battleborn and and samade amigo and some
other stuff this is pretty awesome this
is like i'm pretty proud of this history
there's a lot of great content here um
but now a lot of you guys don't know
some of you know that gearbox is now
also a publisher we're not just gearbox
software the gearbox entertainment
company and i was gearbox publishing and
gearbox publishing doesn't just publish
gearbox games but it also publishes
other developers games and the
publishing group has really been kicking
ass can we get out the the other one
with the the publishing games here i'll
i'm gonna make more room for you
look at all this
and like killer stuff any um
anybody check out tribes of midgard that
game was awesome um risk of rain too
killer like one of the best roguelikes
ever made and these incredible
developers are trusting gearbox
publishing to
to support them and to help their
products reach you guys help their games
reach you guys and we you know as
developers we always wanted to create
the publisher that we wished we always
had we wanted to be the most developer
friendly publisher in the world and
we've got some really cool stuff to talk
about that's coming from gearbox
publishing and to do that i want to
introduce the president of gearbox
publishing let's hear it for steve
gibson steve you back there
[Applause]
all right buddy cheers steve gibson
hello everybody
it has been an honor to build a
publisher here at gearbox it has been an
honor
to work with so many of these talented
developers willing to trust us with
their games
it has been a wonderful journey we've
been doing this for just shy of a decade
i want to show a couple things to you
guys of course today
i'm really proud of what we've done so
far and i'm really really proud of what
we're about to show you today
so homeworld is a beloved franchise
that has not seen a sequel
in about 20 years
there's a lot of expectation about what
that would be
there's a lot of love for what that
would be and hope to be
and we've been spending a lot of time
with blackbird trying to make sure it's
just right
now what we've done is you may have seen
at gamescom
we showed off for the first time a
little bit of that gameplay about what
homeworld 3 will be
what blackbird and gearbox imagine the
future that franchise to be
and we're here today we want to show you
what we're going to call an extended
director's cut
of what a gameplay trailer looks like in
homeworld 3.
so please have a look
[Music]
has been damaged and gate control
modules are in disarray resource
controllers standing by to execute
repairs
[Music]
did you track that hostile signal i was
there for a moment then nothing
fighters inside the structure it's an
ambush they are targeting our resources
all interceptors
there it is
[Applause]
but we lost some good pilots expecting
additional contact requesting
reinforcements
adjusting approach vector for cover
[Music]
targeting
use the old surface tunnels and approach
from the rear cover
attention all
group on units the carrier all remaining
hostile forces must be eliminated to
ensure safe gate transit
bombers standing by
assault frigate production online keep
the resources
[Music]
the resourcing operation is under attack
first squadron to support positions
immediately understood fleet will be
outnumbered but we've seen worse
coordinates locked in stay tight and
pick your targets
[Music]
long enough to build another wave of
bombers to finish off that carrier
[Music]
[Music]
one of the enemy missile frigates is
isolated use the resource controller to
capture
three
two
one mark
[Music]
[Applause]
man
i am so excited for that you guys will
be playing that game next year you will
be blowing up so much [ __ ]
it has been a fun fun ride and to now
have you know games and teams that we're
working with of course hyper light
around the corner really excited about
the next gamer there those gentlemen
over at hopu and the risk of rain just
keeps on going that's been a delight
and most recently of course tribes of
midgard and and um
and light and dark have both
been received really well and millions
of you guys are playing those games
man it's a lot of fun and in fact we're
bringing those games more places more
content i wanted to take a look at a
little bit more we have for tribes of
mid-dark midgard and light and dark
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
woof
man i still called it by the old name we
named internally sorry about that
wow so
i won't spend any more of your guys's
time you have so much more to get to
here at the show um thank you so much
for supporting all these developers
thank you so much for being supportive
of gearbox and our ambition to entertain
the world and i want to introduce you to
one of my favorite people
erica stead
erica
hey pax
so just so you guys know
steve only said that nice thing about me
because he's the person that picked me
out in the first place
um so
i didn't see the show of hands earlier
how many of you here have been to
gearbox panels before
all right all right so you guys probably
know
that i am here to talk to you about toys
and t-shirts and all of that stuff
[Applause]
except this time i'm not
so something else that we have been
doing in licensing is working on some
interactive licensing projects and we've
been working with some different
partners to bring our ips and our
universes into new spaces in the
interactive universe
so one of these things that we have been
working on is a homeworld digital
pinball game with our partners at zen
studios and they have done a really good
job taking the majesty and the
atmosphere of homeworld and combining
that with the
fun and challenging nature of pinball
and they now have released our new
homeworld journey to hegara pinball
table in their pinball fx game
and without further ado
i'm going to let you guys see it
[Applause]
all systems online
mothership and position
hyperspace successful
welcome to the fleet
destination confirmed
all
priority alert right mother ship all
units
mothership threat confirmed
[Music]
but wait there's more
so all of you guys who are here with us
live today are going to be getting a
code for
that pinball table for free
[Music]
all right i know you guys like free
stuff right
[Music]
all right
randy likes it when you guys are high
energy and hyped so come on let's
[Applause]
[Music]
they're ready for you now
that that pinball machine is awesome and
i hope you guys uh that are here live
with us enjoy it it's free if you're
home sorry you're gonna have to pay a
few bucks but uh it's worth it it's
worth it um uh it's become tradition
those of you that have been coming to
pax gearbox main theater shows for a
while for me to do a magic trick
okay um
for this one uh i'm gonna need some help
so i've got a method to get somebody at
random uh oh yeah cool
uh we're gonna we're gonna we got a d20
here
uh in fact i'm gonna throw this out in
the audience bounce it around for a
while
uh and then we're gonna let this settle
somewhere and pick somebody at random
can we agree that this is a fair choice
that if this thing bounces around
there's no possible way can you can you
throw that behind you yeah knock that
around just let it go and we'll let the
music go for a while um it's absolutely
critical
that you believe beyond a shadow of a
doubt that whoever it is that this ends
up with it's a random free choice
how long do you think we should let the
music run
i don't know i'm going to turn around or
i'll just close my eyes
and ahern when you when you're ready
back there sean ahearn's on tech uh just
stop the music and that'll whoever's got
it that'll be our spectator whenever
you're ready
where is it
you
what's hold on hold on what's your name
sagan
paul paul uh kat is our enforcer over
here can you walk over to kat and she's
going to help you get backstage there's
no way up the front if you run here
you're going to smash into all this
equipment and break things including
yourself so cat will help you get on
stage um thank you paul so paul's our
lucky volunteer
paul do you get
do you guys trust him
well he he is uh he is your spokesperson
on behalf of the audience for this uh
paul
welcome
welcome to the gearbox main theater show
uh you want to shake my hand
i'm randy nice to meet you paul uh let's
come up here and let's talk for a second
um
paul um
have you i don't know if you how many of
those games do you think you played
[Music]
a couple of them
two or three look around here there's
some interesting stuff right
i've um amazing he said everything on
from the top shelf on that he's played
um we're gonna we're gonna let we're
gonna have you pick one at random and
it's gotta be a random choice oh you
know what here paul why don't you take
this so if i need to talk to you we can
hear you we're gonna have you pick one
at random i don't want you to make a
conscious choice though so can i get a
bag i have a bag back there somewhere
can someone
i need a bag we're going to put all the
games in a bag and you're going to
shuffle them up and grab them can we get
the ba there we go
yeah thanks yeah thank you
right we got you know what this is my
laundry bag um
let me get you remember to clean it
right yeah this is my laundry bags get
all the laundry out of here
we're gonna get those
we don't need the laundry
um
all right can you um
let's uh let's start putting the games
in the bag let's just let's just get
them in there go ahead and just start
throwing them in
here you want any help or do you you
don't trust me
it's fine just get them in there all
right paul we're going to get all the
games in the bag including the
publishing ones yeah all everything you
know
and um
uh
what we're going to do here paul
is
i'm going to show you remember earlier
when i was talking about the lego mosaic
stuff oh boy i got really really good at
it i'm gonna make a mosaic live
uh in front of you
uh yeah when i started it took me like i
was joking i said it took me five hours
but during the pandemic i i uh
my uh my f my
my spotify i couldn't figure out how to
get it off loop and so i put the i put a
song on and it would just play the same
song over and over and over again and it
was connected through like my home audio
system and it was like a pain in the ass
to go to the place to like um
uh to um
uh to fix it so i was just basically
playing the same song over and over and
over and over again and this song
happens to be about two minutes and 55
seconds long and because there's
something about how the brain works
where when you have music playing you
just want to um
you just kind of want to finish when the
song finishes
and i got to the point where i could do
a mosaic in two minutes and 55 seconds
it would just perfectly line up exactly
as the song ended every time um and
we're going to start in a minute i'm
don't start it yet but in a minute we're
going to have you here you're going to
you're going to stand right here
um
and i want you to reach inside randomly
grab one just grab the anyone you want
and you got one
you could just take one what'd you get
surprised
oh [ __ ] new tales from the borderlands
that's not even out yet
okay um
uh new tales from the borderlands and
look on the cover is um
is louis this is the new character i
don't know if you guys can see louie
there uh
which which am i this camera yeah
so i'm gonna build a mosaic of louie in
two minutes and 55 seconds
all right you hold this
um
we're gonna we're gonna see if we can do
this now it's you know it's i gotta make
it magical so i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
hide the action i'm gonna hide the work
behind this uh
this little guy here um are you are you
ready back there should we start the
music two minutes and 55 seconds you
guys can time me if you want but the
song will do it you might recognize the
song let's go
[Music]
you ready oh no no no no no
just
don't stop i haven't done it yet haven't
done it yet you ready let's start the
song again one more time let's do it
start the song
one second
oh here we go
okay a little bit faster than two
minutes and 55 seconds and uh this is
legit
that's louie and that's lego and you can
keep that
um but here's the thing you can't keep
this this is an object that is fair i
completely understand but thanks for
helping me out um in addition to that i
want to leave you with something else uh
this wasn't my laundry i lied um these
are uh
uh froger shirts from new tales from the
borderlands
uh you can have one of those too uh and
when you go off stage um dan's gonna
get your information because we're gonna
give you codes where you can get the
whole gearbox catalog digital
thanks uh
thanks for helping us paul cheers all
right and hey can we give a quick shout
out to nerd bonnie james for bookers and
badasses oh hell yeah thank you thanks
paul
he's not a plant i swear
that was a
he's he's uh you want a job though like
i mean
wow
um uh
i got some more of these
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wait it's a lilith cosplay right
there
who else wants some
[Music]
oh what's going to help
i got all kinds of clothes i'm gonna i'm
just gonna give all these away
ah
[Applause]
oh that guy that guy of course
that guy really wanted one um
oh don't kill each other for it
um
oh shoot pass it back if you're ready to
go um so
uh these shirts are pretty cool they're
okay
but i mean
[Applause]
this uh this shirt i'm wearing actually
is um you know some people know that i
like to wear fun shirts um uh my wife
dresses me she i just look in the closet
whatever's there but um she usually gets
shirts from um
robert graham
the designer out of new york they're
really fancy
and uh they're kind of expensive
um and i'm not saying that because i'm
trying to brag or anything but my wife
really loves me so she's hooking me up
um
oh wait a minute
our two psychos over here see you guys
[Applause]
awesome you guys look great um
she got to the point
she got to the point where she got like
a hundred of these shirts like a hundred
of them um and robert graham uh they
called her up and said hey uh
you're pretty hardcore um
maybe we should make a custom shirt so
this is that shirt um this is uh this
shirt is actually you can look it up
robert graham borderlands this shirt is
called borderlands i like the embroidery
stuff so i got like crazy embroidery
here but you can see that kind of this
alien landscape i made an alien with the
two moons um this shirt is awesome i
have a lot of shirts and i got so many
that um you know it's time to kind of
turn over some of the the closet a
little bit so i i took a bunch of my
shirts
and i gave them to dan hewitt uh to said
hey let's do something cool with this
and uh dan set up this thing where we're
gonna auction off uh these shirts and
give the money to charity uh damn
let's get dan out here to talk about it
everybody i'm back
what what uh
what charity are we hooking up so we are
actually going to be auctioning off more
than 40 of your shirts
and 100 of the proceeds are gonna go to
video game scholarships yes and so these
are somehow those yes so follow every
one of these shirts i've worn uh some of
them i've worn on the stage they've been
dry cleaned yeah so
go ahead and talk about it dan all right
thanks you guys see you in a minute
so
you guys have heard us talk about at
gearbox our mission is to entertain the
world and we firmly believe to entertain
the world we need to be of the world and
help develop the next generation of game
creators and we know that there are a
lot of folks out there who are studying
at eu colleges universities to get a
video game design degree and they're
having a tough time so we are going to
be auctioning off these shirts and all
the proceeds are going to go to
scholarships for up-and-coming
developers
this auction is going to be going on for
the next week
please go ahead and check out the site
be generous
and wear your t-shirt or wear your randy
pitchford uh shirt with pride
and that would be great all right
yeah
um
want to auction the shirt off right now
this one's been on stage you guys want
the board somebody's somebody didn't get
a french wait wait before we do this do
you have a shirt on underneath
yeah yeah okay yeah says now that we can
do it
this shirt is coming by the way if
anybody when you get them i'm happy to
like sign them or like take photos or
share photos and be wearing them or
whatever perfect
this okay so here we go all right so
this is the borderlands shirt that randy
was talking about that is designed just
for us you all literally saw him wear it
let's start the auction wait i can't see
out there so many people holy crap there
are a lot of people out here
uh
all right so what do we think let's
start with 25 for this shirt 25 by the
way
these shirts range like new from like
200 to like 700 dollars and somewhere in
that range and this is a limited edition
so this is on the higher end of that
range limited edition oh get signed and
you'll get a picture with randy
afterwards in fact go you can go on
search on ebay right now there was a
there's a women's cut of the same shirt
called siren and i looked just yesterday
there was a borderland siren that was on
ebay for like 250 oh my gosh
all right it's not even new it's used
and it wasn't worn by me
[Laughter]
wait what did i hear 300.
do it 300 325.
three wait do i see 325.
500.
five oh wait do i hear more
wait what's that
six hundred dollars you're helping
future developers
afford to learn how to do this stuff so
they can make cool entertainment for you
this is what this is for this is a
really good cause all right i got 600
back here what do i have up here
750 come on you're gonna let him have it
for
800.
all right
come on you're gonna are we're gonna let
it go for 800. we're going to go for
more come on let's go 825.
i'm sorry how much
900 oh my god
950 back in the back
wait oh
[Music]
there we go
wait who set a thousand
there you go
1200.
holy [ __ ] y'all this is getting real
i thought we'd get like 300 this is
amazing
we got 1200 back here what do we got
more what do we have more we're going to
grab more anything else
1200 1200 going once
1200 going twice
sold for 1200.
that's [ __ ] amazing
come up here
get get get their name so that whichever
developer ends up getting the
scholarship knows
where that money came from absolutely i
tell you what come on over here to the
side and we'll get you set up amazing
one more round
twelve hundred dollars for video game
scholarship that's awesome
uh okay well with that i'm going to get
the qr code there's 40 shirts up there
um i needed room in my closet and uh but
they're they're all you can smell my
sweat if you're into that i don't know
um no he cleaned it he cleaned them
uh are we good we're good guys um one of
the cool things about this environment
is we can uh kind of like spend more
time with things than we can like when
we go to you know some of the bigger
shows like when we go to like opening
night live you may some of you guys
might have saw at gamescom we had the
first trailer when i went on stage to
announce new tales from the borderlands
right i don't know if did anybody watch
the trailer
that was a short trailer we've got a lot
more for you here today a lot of people
are very very curious
about new tales from the borderlands and
uh i'm very excited because today we've
got a bunch of awesome people from the
tales team uh that i'm going to
introduce to come out on stage and set
up this new uh this new trailer for you
so um uh uh actually are you guys ready
back there so uh we got a few folks from
the team we've got um dr lynn joyce uh
from the writing team let's welcome dr
lynn joyce
we got uh
uh j.lo james lopez who i affectionately
refer to as jlo uh he's the uh student
producer director production
uh and uh
and uh up on the creative team at
gearbox studio quebec fred shubo fred
come on out here the fred's uh producing
crap
and uh i thought i'd introduce you guys
and i think i should just shut up and
let you guys set up the trailer and this
is like your team's hard work made this
awesome game that i absolutely love
tell them about it
thanks randy hello pax how's everyone
doing right now
hello and bonjour to our quebecer
friends and family in the audience with
us today we are so excited to be on
stage today to talk to you about new
tales from the borderlands and i'm
personally so excited to be back on the
stage because it's been a few years
since last time that we did a play along
for a telst in the borderlands game uh
new york you're doing a play along oh
[ __ ] are we
we are
we are
new tales from the borderlands is a game
that was developed at gearbox studio
quebec with fred schubel and his team
they're an amazingly talented group of
people that have been with us since
borderlands 3. uh they've been doing a
lot of really really awesome work and
this is their debut game uh before we
get super duper into it we're going to
show you a quick trailer about the
characters in this game so let's go and
play that jon whenever you're ready
[Music]
so you're still running your parents
frogger store that is adorable
as soon as the insurance money comes in
this place will look good as new
susan caldwell
she wrecked my shop oh that corporate
butt sniffer and i have a polyamorous
date with my punching fist
getting on forge's super successful
dirty 30 is a lifelong dream it's
irrefutable proof to the rest of the
world that i'll gave you wallace stark
exists
but i'm a somebody you however are not
on this list you're anonymous
unrecognized and nobody
we use innovation and technology to help
people and protect life not casually
destroy it as a matter of course
you're a revolutionary boss we are on
the cusp of a world
with less bloodshed
we could
change the world for the better get
freaking famous kick susan caldwell's
ass let's take the fight to them just
tell me who to shoot and where to shoot
him are you flirting with me
you are dead now that's a pitch
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much
as i was saying this is gsq's first
title completely on their own it's very
awesome uh this is a the next game in
the tales from the borderlands franchise
and even though it is the next game in
the franchise it is a standalone title
it's a spiritual successor but otherwise
it has a completely new story new
characters and a brand new adventure and
rather than me hog all the space talking
about the story i'm actually going to
pass to our doctor of storytelling len
joyce thank you all right pax are you
ready to hear about our new tale
all right so here's what you need to
know ahead of the gameplay demo
new tales from the borderlands takes
place about a year after the events of
borderlands 3.
and our primary setting is the planet of
promethea
this time though we're shining the
spotlight on a different corporation
tidior
tdrs come to promethia looking for maybe
the last thing anyone would expect to
find there
another
vault
our trio of protagonists who you just
met have stumbled onto tdore's plan and
they are each uniquely motivated to want
to stop them
despite having zero qualifications
when it comes to vault hunting they are
going to follow tidior
into the sewers of promethea in a wild
gambit to get into a vault
fight for their dreams and maybe even
change the world
so without further ado i'm gonna pass
the puck over to fred to set up our
gameplay demo
so uh
we're about to play new tales from the
borderlands together
what you have to know is that choice is
the biggest feature of the game so every
choice is important not only because of
the humor tied to every choice option
but also because every choice can lead
to further ramifications down the story
line so without further ado i'll grab
the controller and you guys tell me
which button you want me to press and
we'll we'll just dive right in
all right
[Applause]
if i can get the controller
here we are
you ready
all right let's do
if the it is on oh yeah
controller presses maybe it's not the
right controller
is the uh light on the x technical
difficulties
oh oh ooh and away we go
here we go definitely continue
we don't have the 10 hours it takes to
get to this point otherwise
you've got a secret sewer exit built
into your shop
yeah
i
okay cool yes
if you see any bodies down here pretend
you didn't
why would we
talk about something we definitely won't
see got it thank you
[ __ ]
good friend of mine
shut up
decent friend
do you want to die
acquaintance
you're heading into a battalion of
tyrion troops how do you know that
i snuck a tracker into your clothes in
case i ever needed to kill you stay
quiet
[Applause]
what
on-site procurement military stealth
lingo
ah you made that up
going dark
tdr troops ahead gotta be sneaky what
how i'm not a covert operative just stay
low and follow my lead well just you
know stay quiet and avoid them all hold
up i love you but i would never put the
words quiet and octavio in the same
solar system as each other you got a
better idea
soldier can't scream with a crushed
windpipe
wait
so our options are to sneak around and
pray nobody swats us or
quietly murder everyone we come
across so uh for violence
i don't love unnecessary violence but it
does seem like fran knows what she's
doing
yeah of course totally understand
all right get behind me and stay light
on your feet in case you gotta dodge any
people juice ah
okay
this is gonna talk about it okay
it's
so normally in one of these games what
would happen at the top right corner is
it would say octavia will remember that
but we've kind of moved away from that
because we want you to feel that every
choice you make matters and so we've
leaned more into the incredible
performances of our actors who shot for
over a year straight to get this done on
time for this event so instead of having
the little notification we instead have
things like octavia going no it's fine
when you know it's not really that fine
we're letting the characters tell you
how they feel
here we go
[Applause]
now len would you say that that tv or
trooper needed to cool off a little bit
would you say that
i would say you're fired
go go go
wherever they're going we'd better
follow
oh crap won't be able to cross the room
without him seeing us
you can't like zoom up to him and knock
him out chair gets loud if i move too
fast everyone in the sewers will hear us
it's okay
i got an idea
you're about to see one of octavio's
many brilliant i like it
but i gotta say your brother has
problems octavio what are you doing as
long as i move only when he's not
looking you'll think i'm
just there
[Applause]
here we go
careful fred
careful
[Applause]
just let me uh
i'm not who you're looking for
i disagree
is up
no
it couldn't be
don't worry much in the market but to a
true ball lander connoisseur
my vault lender
you want it it's yours just let me go
i'm not gonna take it
to the right of glorious combat
you wanna
fight
indeed i do
will versus will
vaughtlander to voters
[Music]
isn't
no
to us anymore octavio must find glory in
the truth of the figures only through
plastic combat will our fates
be decided why are you people like this
ready
[Applause]
[Music]
fight
[Applause]
this is gonna hurt
front lookout
[Music]
lookouts
ghetto
[Applause]
i respect your superior combat skills
leave this place
i must gather my thoughts
okay we're uh gonna go this way
no more
so this is vault landers which is one of
the new mini games that we've introduced
into this game and it originally started
off with this thing that was just going
to be like a little collectible sort of
thing that happened throughout and then
one day we're like
what if we turn into a fighting game and
then we're like what if we did and this
is what came out of it game development
magic right there
should be
conspicuous right
or are they
i mean this could be the bulk entrance
right here
try it
[Music]
three tdr soldiers of questionable
intelligence stand between us and the
vault
fran can you take them
is frogert better than ice cream
what are we doing are we sure do we risk
it
never been sure before
why start now
i heard someone say brisket i'm like
yeah sure get that we should keep it
that way so let them get closer and
closer to the vault because
because tdr may not be the worst thing
looking around here and whoever has the
vault key is going to be the primary
target
if i'm not cracking skulls what do you
propose we do
there's some cover down there we could
try to i don't know get closer
we'll have to be extremely quiet
yeah it's a stealth mission
sorry
all this sneaking better lead up to some
violence
it will
probably
just follow me and make sure they don't
see you
no
all right let's go that's right
so
this looks like an opening confirmed
that's an opening
opening confirmed you got the key you go
first
wait wait hold on a second
i think you've done it yes it's opening
yeah
[Music]
lost a little audio there for a second
there we go
confirmed
should we
[Music]
dan says we gotta stop and i gotta
respect him he's my flight home
no big deal just a couple of alien
warriors pretty sure they didn't see us
time to
gonna get us out of here
knuckles
no sweat
you okay
nothing a little adrenaline won't fix
i'm sorry octavio
we can figure this out they're just
aliens
more like robots
the iridians apparently had them built
to guard the vault before they pissed
off to whatever dimension they're
probably hiding in
what
i read
the point is we are done we'll be lucky
just to find a way out of here with our
lives this is our last choice every last
choice everyone whatever's in that
[Applause]
might be worth box
we've come this far we can't just leave
are you aware of the sunk cost fallacy
yes anu i've sunk a fallacy before
uh
we're safer here than out there or back
in the sewers in fact this is the safest
we've been in hours
the only way out is through all right
friends
that's where we have to stop
unfortunately we have to be
we have to be good
you will be able to watch the rest of
this demo
a little later online so if you want to
see what happens next check in online
check social we'll have the links there
for you and thank you all so much we
love you all thank you for all the love
and support we'll see you in october
take care
thank you amazing that was amazing thank
you guys good job buddy that was can we
get a one more round of applause it's
not easy to play games
in front of everybody here that was
incredible and i cannot wait
for new tales to come out on october
21st so
we're wrapping up
i want to thank everybody for joining us
for our pax west gearbox main theater
show before you go want to give away
some more things
if you go to gearboxloot.com
you can you there's a code that you can
use and it is pax west 2022 and that
will get you 20
off of everything that you buy in
gearboxloot.com so be take advantage of
that that will wrap up september 5th uh
so that's a great deal for you i also
want to thank our friends at 2k without
whom this show would be much much harder
and they are great partners and friends
of ours so thank you 2k i also want to
thank our partners at zen studios for
giving us the
homeworld pinball game code and you can
get those at the door on your way out
and as a reminder we've got the live
auction for randy shirts that will go to
help fund video game developers
scholarships so take advantage of that
and one last thing holy crap this is
like such a long psa for everybody
one last thing if you love gearbox and
who loves gearbox
who would love to come work at
gearbox we have a twitter feed for you
go to gearbox jobs we have a ton of jobs
available for folks across a wide degree
of departments so check it out come join
us and make some incredible kick-ass
games all right everybody oh wait one
more thing sorry uh and if you're in
seattle this weekend we're gonna have
fran's froger truck uh and we are giving
away free frozen yogurt and this is the
truck from uh new tales from the
borderlands and that's going to be
parked over at westlake park so head on
over there all weekend and take
advantage of the free frozen yogurt that
we're giving away there and now we're
done thanks everybody have a great pax
west
[Music]
foreign